c'est une tradition les places de
stationnement dans les communes seront
gratuites durant toute la période d'août
une initiative mise en place entre
autres pour les 4750 place sur la
commune du chéné rocancourt et le
millier de places de montigny le
bretonneux le stationnement résidentiel
est essentiellement un outil de
régulation et surtout une grande partie
de la population part en vacances avec
son véhicule pendant voilà le mois
d'août et donc on a pas on n'a pas
besoin de se servir de cet outil est
donc traditionnellement le stationnement
est gratuit y compris en zone rouge près
aussi palmans les places payantes se
trouve sur le quartier centre est donc
là ça ça permet sur la partie voie
publique d'avoir des parkings à
disposition et donc d'encourager le
développement économique surtout à cette
année particulière bien que les places
soient gratuites pour fluidifier la
circulation
les communes réguler les stationnements
pour éviter les voitures ventouses les
voitures ventouses c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas directement relié au
stationnement résidentiel
c'est du stationnement gênant et donc
que le stationnement sur gratuits ou
payants
vous n'avez pas le droit de rester plus
de sept jours au même endroit et à
partir de là vous êtes verbalisable les
places gratuites dans les zones de
centre ville permettent aussi aux
commerces de recevoir plus de clients
les habitants les premiers concernés par
cette initiative sont plutôt satisfaits
je trouve que c'est bien bah on va dire
que ça profite plus aux gens criaient
son dû qui restent ici sur le mois
d'août donc ça peut être intéressant
pour pouvoir les dents les commerçants
qui reste ouvert pour certaines communes
comme versailles et saint germain en
laye ou encore poissy le stationnement
reste encore payant pendant le mois
d'août pour les villes qui offrent la
gratuité
il faudra passer à l'horodateur dès le
1er septembre